the man which is back yes they
definitely heard that that a lot so this
is the blood under the skin and this
episode where Finn after defeating a
very vicious ladybug has to go and get
he doesn't have to go a guitar but he
just wants armor cuz he got splinter and
he thinks a little thin bull would be
enough but they sees other people with
armor and he gets jealous so he goes to
juice goose was that one's going juice
juice goose he is amazing you know the
one thing about that character that's
like how do I put I actually wish I I
wish they used to less of him so I
wanted more of him if that makes any
sense
like when he just says sure I'm just
doing so I was saying myself if that was
it if we never saw him again the episode
might just be hilarious cuz you'd be
like what's that guy's story or what's
he about no capture the glitch so
something he does pop up boring there is
there was one particular movements like
before he gets slapped and he just does
this weird movement like his head is
getting slapped because my absolute
favorites and all at some point just
really wanted to slap a goose we did
earlier I hate those things
they're from Canada yep not the juice
goose though no he's from Edwin land oh
my god I'm just imagining Edwin land is
they're like oh so okay so he has to go
on this quest to like it's do they ever
say it's like a quest of embarrassment
or so I'm doing okay just all these
appearances yeah just all these
embarrassing things have to happen and
again I lost a Serb pushing what you can
show it like he's constantly seeing
people naked
literally using your butt to pick up a
bomb oh my god that was amazing cuz it's
like finally I know what the name of
their game is cuz used to play that all
the time
yeah are we gonna play a little bit
after well Doug was insisting I was I
you know whatever part of the body picks
it up um as long as it's something that
involves something disgusting and you
and all of us together in our manwich
then I am fine okay you're gonna use
your prehensile penis aren't you
I thought we agreed we wouldn't talk
about that on camera so I will believe
that later big brought up drop balls so
we just had to go there you know what
I'm coming up with that then yeah no
yeah we've just got a lot I can't ride a
bike and I have that under the pants so
we're all finding what's under our armor
it's kind of like Jake is your penis Lee
no it's more of a rap piece or the snake
you know I don't think we're gonna talk
about this right now we're going to talk
about how he gets to do you see our bird
gets the armor and he puts it on but
it's female armor but Jake doesn't mind
so he puts it on and defeats the ghost
and there's this guy what's the name of
the guy the guy I know were a number of
good said that I can't hear it on the
night there like you know Sircar LA or
something I couldn't hear it but the guy
the pig chorus wit just like it would be
like any other designed to be any other
badass design except they give them a
pink course that just suddenly makes
them stand out I mean he's doing black
with like blood droplets on his armor
and everything but you guys on a pink
course yeah it's like all those things
are just like dog drop bald fin back
you blink and you miss it like what yeah
it's the fact that yeah it's the fact
here that he's just like you know I
learned something new I'm gonna use it
so he he keeps following Finn around
which vid points out you're just
following a boy around why like that's
pretty embarrassing and he gets
embarrassed in return but is not
gloriously proud of it instead it's just
embarrassing
but Finn has embraced his embarrassment
cuz a dog has picked him up with his
butt and anyone would be embarrassed by
that and then they run through three
mountains and that's I just want the
random destruction three beautiful
mountains just gone because you know
what doesn't mind uestion is remember
way back in that episode with the
mountain that was alive two mountains
that were alive what if Jake just
literally back in alive mountain well
they cut off the head of like this one
monster and let it be a frog home I mean
I feel I can see these other episodes
now talking mountains that we may have
just killed in this episode yeah you
know I think they will have at the very
least said ouch still talk and see a few
say go ahead can see can't talk you
probably seventh a canary no that'll be
guessing this no no no but it can still
I'm sure it know depending where you get
off all right we're chopping to set up
I'm not a mouse to insist get it over
with the mountain okay no hey hey we
would need a mountain
are you really fucking getting a knife I
hope so I'm sure he's really good
like a cleaver dude he wants to put this
to the test will do dissect that Oh
let's give him a splinter - hey you know
what I I'm not gonna have this man wish
v-log anymore because clearly all it is
they just want to gang up on Doug and
that's not cool I don't like that um how
long does it take you to put a knife
away
I'm grabbing you a specialist you can
defend yourself yeah plus you wander
demons nice so the advantage is mine no
way he gave you something so you gotta
go do you think the Zelda rod was a
reference to Zelda by the way of course
it was pretty sure affected its female
armor yeah that too
so yeah I guess it is one of those where
I sort of think about it like well okay
like there's some interesting stuff
going on about like you know Finn being
in Ferris and you know come to grips
with it's okay to be embarrassed and the
guy at the end like his armor does even
work that well yes is a giant white
thing and Jake's like I think she wants
you to nurse you when they saw that yeah
so yeah it's one of those where it's
like I know there's like some
interesting stuff going on but like it's
hard to get like a clear-cut
like impression of what it's kind of
about I guess just embrace embarrassment
and don't be just if it helps you
why did help you don't care how it makes
you Walker hey even if you have to play
drop I'm gonna call Simpsons on this why
does it always have to be you have to be
a point you know yeah why can it be just
a bunch of stuff that happens well I
think what you learn from this is don't
get it don't get addicted to drop ball
and go out into the Sun there's many
layers to this
and don't be afraid to people on old
people in the shower again the show's
obsession with hurting or defacing old
people if there's a lot of old people to
facing in this show oh man you gotta go
back now you gotta watch a lot of like
to go watch the old people destruction
it's fun um the Astrakhan III guess
because it is more of an embarrassment
one I like the ones we get to see more
the creative creatures and the words and
creative stuff like that it's no thing
was was pretty cool I like how they just
somehow climbed through her to like just
comes through in grabs them to go on
their back I'm like what is this the -
yeah so yeah it's fine
I liked it bye what am i one of my
favorite scenes and it's very fast is
the month of minstrel where after he
plays his song and everything any the
nights about to just ride up you just
goes whoop scoops him up and need to see
him on the back of the horse
yeah always has this mystery what's he
just always carries him around he never
knows what he might beat him no I just
said you never know we might be a
spatula I'm just gonna have this like an
everyday walk now like just you never
know it's like the towel and it's my
lucky spatula this is a spatula city
we spent olicity and then it's these
it's the Hitchhiker's Guide tile except
it's a spatula now you just never know
what you might need it oh no no don't
make them panic well I thought the most
interesting degree what I haven't even
finished oh you
the most interesting thing I thought was
how sin things who just turned dark in a
matter of seconds
like whatever they're fighting the ghost
you know like everything's been funny
the ghost was the one that showed him
the amazing game of drop ball which
everyone should try who says we have
truth
remember the premium tell penis didn't
he start sucking out his soul yeah like
oh that was a tryst II just like good
good progress enjoyed they love too much
everybody like so lucky what can I say
and and the only other thing I can think
of that I really start watching this
episode you know I was talking about the
very basic designs and how simple they
are well I mean in terms of like the
line work and I realized that I think by
having those simple that simple layout
it allows the motion of them to be much
more sporadic I think they can focus
more on them because it's just they're
so easy to draw it's just da dies you
can sort of do whatever you want with
them so it also allows you to do things
cheaply very very cheap I mean it it's
kind of true but even something like
what you ever say worth Jake's watch
goes and grabs is it stuff like that
like if this was a very complicated you
know design of me that'd be very hard to
animate but because it's so simple they
can just you know do it very quickly and
very easy I disagree I want a team of at
least a hundred Koreans animating that I
want everything animated brush and I'm
gonna see the quartz on that dog 0.o dog
putts grabbing boys right there backs
I'm glad he go start a Kickstarter get
it going your dream will come true
somebody make a video of just like the
ending climax please turn into a monster
and it's like you know goodnight up but
like it translate out to drop ball and
just like see what people say like don't
connect it back down sorry I'm just
handling a video and just be like you
know the comment don't be like I get
this I understand we're trying to get
people away from drop on to go up to the
Sun I say more yes your morale yeah more
drop ball with dogs
ah teach your dog how to do it outside
and you can see leaves with snails on
them but you can't play drop ball out
there
why not are you embarrassed no my drop
buster
you know all I'm gonna say is this drop
ball and shakespeareans most beautiful
sonnets I'm gonna go with drop ball I
agree
well done Network yes and creators of
this show well done well done
I said we played through up all right
now yeah